let's start here welcome to this video I
am em Western this is the opponent let's
see who's taking the lead in our mini
match it's 12 12 12 12 yeah this camp I
didn't fare too well with this line I
should probably look at this a little
bit i think i had exactly the same thing
in an earlier game have black gets this
quickly fine Wow and like that but okay
at least I'm getting castled there's
some tech Takeo anything i don't i don't
see it so that's castle isn't that deep
one week i mean if i go look to you one
or so see if either that's night before
but 94 it this is possible yeah
so takes it and see for all right yes
still see for my idea is that he will
he'd still need some time to regain the
material and he has a slightly weakened
King position so this is something that
can prove helpful in the long run so
take here okay wait takes it can
actually takes it to take g3 and this is
a technical problem so what do I do 93 a
spoon
hmm I need to be able to play maybe
rookie won this position I probably will
see eight I would like to unpin here
queen bee three night g3 takes Bishop
Jake's that loses a pawn let loose a
pawn
hmm i don't really see a good move to be
perfectly honest I move that I totally
like yes whatever I do it seems that I'm
I'm so good worse I know this is not
what I wanted and I took took her a
million years to play it now in this
kind of fool move I could have played
like immediately so this is what it's
the the bad the worst part of it and
this is actually didn't feel at all I
think yeah I'm okay I thought you would
take with the porn that was much
stronger yeah I always have enough
counter play on the dark squares if not
more than that
maybe you can take this actually after
Bishop TX my bishop is unprotected what
now whoopsie seven maybe oops is seven
shooting for FC won a group c 8 i would
like to enter with the queen of course
don't see how time whining don't see how
my bishop should come to de force would
be extremely helpful
going for Bishop b5 254 now I didn't see
Roxy for it's a helpful trade for black
you should just take the rook now should
be happy to change the rogue check no he
does
I have enough compensation for the poor
Nia cannot even keep keep it spawns now
check and check check check
yeah I spent this is this absolutely
ridiculous time earlier in the game and
this is now coming back to haunt me 26
seconds actually funnier because Bishop
c5 is pretty annoying I can also check
you
yeah I'm better now but you know it is
this time issue oh don't want to trade
Jack no my queen oh come on I really
hate this what is he know what the heck
what is happening at the bow bird this
is just stupid I have the better game
yet and it's I'm getting close time wise
and then I blunder the Queen in one move
this is super ridiculous really yeah
many widest playing for the wind very
conveniently because I have the better
structure six as we get I can torch him
forever young but like wheat to be five
I mean okay not forever because we both
have like 10 seconds but yeah anyway yet
I think I never was in danger here you
have enough compensation I think this is
a huge mistake Quincy form it just has
to take with the pawn this is the only
move that gives black any chances to do
something here I think I have very good
compensation for the corner because of
his back bad King side position or bad
King position I mean why does absolutely
not in any danger any question is so can
you can you do something or not I think
he played it well yes trading all this
and here i think you should conveniently
draw young can I can just take a seven
years I mean I had to be a quick because
of the time taking air seven was a lot
stronger of course check
but okay I always right always keeps
keeps a grip on this position I hear
Bishop f6 was possible I am can I just
took took ages early on because I
couldn't even okay this is actually not
that interesting because it was decided
by time so yeah so I came night b5 is
stronger okay yeah 497 yeah yeah I
couldn't find a good solution I mean
this this was I mean I saw early that I
can do that as some kind of I don't find
anything bad ever I took like two
minutes here this is ridiculous this is
ridiculous right yeah currently i'm just
giving away points left and right and
most of these games i shouldn't
shouldn't lose really bad position okay
maybe i can stop the bleeding after this
game thanks for watching